let's try one of these out together to see what happens. How about one of these
more difficult ones. Let's say g of g inverse of x. g of x is 1 4th times the
quantity x minus 9. So in place of x, we need to plug in the function g
inverse, which is 4 x plus 9. So, look at 4 4th times 4x plus 9 minus 9. What
does this simplify to? Inside the parentheses, we just end up with 4x and 1 4th
times 4x is equal to x. Hmm, I'm going to go through and find all these other
compositions right now. Let's see what happens. And it looks like each of these
composite functions is in fact just equal to x. This confirms another
fascinating property of inverse functions. The composition of a function with
its inverse and vice versa will both give us what is known as the identity
function. It's just the independent variable, which in this case is x. So,
another way to think about inverse functions is that the function f inverse
will undo whatever the function f has done to the independent variable. In this
case, f is adding one and f inverse is subtracting one. Here, g is subtracting
9 and then dividing by 4. And g inverse is multiplying by 4 and then adding 9.
Lastly, h cubes and h inverse takes the cube root. I think we're really getting
down to what it fundamentally means for functions to be inverses for one
another. That's really awesome.